Picking someone to take over a role from another
actor is never easy, especially when the original
performer drew praise for their take on that
character. But recasting is often unavoidable,
especially for sequels and remakes. Here are
some more role replacements that ruined movies.
Roger Moore and Sean Connery each
made seven appearances as James Bond,
though many 007 fans will tell
you that Connery is the only Bond.
A CBS News poll concluded that 51 percent of
Americans chose Connery as their favorite Bond,
with Pierce Brosnan coming in a distant second.
George Lazenby, the man who replaced Connery in
the role for 1969's On Her Majesty's Secret
Service, received just 1 percent of the vote,
which tells you everything you need to know
about the gulf between these two actors.
While critical opinion toward the
film itself has softened over time,
Lazenby's performance is still a bone of
contention — inevitably compared to those
delivered by Connery in the franchise's five
previous entries. The Chicago Reader said that,
"George Lazenby has so much reserve as James Bond
that he makes Sean Connery seem
almost frenetic by comparison."
Reviews in the UK were just as critical
of the leading man's turn as the British
Secret Service agent, with
London-based outlet Time
Out calling him a "stunning nonentity"
fronting a film with "no redeeming features."
Following in the footsteps of Linda Hamilton
as Sarah Connor in the Terminator franchise
was never going to be easy — she gave a
performance so layered and compelling that
even the most talented of actresses would
have struggled to do the character justice.
"I volunteered."
"Why?"
"It was a chance to meet
the legend … Sarah Connor."
The first to give it a shot was Lena Headey,
who was cast as the titular heroine in the
short-lived TV series Terminator: The Sarah
Connor Chronicles. Fox canceled the show after
two seasons, leaving Headey's Game of Thrones
colleague Emilia Clarke to carry the torch.
2015's Terminator Genisys was heavily criticized
for using that old time travel chestnut to rewrite
the beginning of the Terminator story to suit
the filmmakers' purposes. The main problem,
however, wasn't the infuriatingly
muddled timeline — it was the casting.
Veteran film critic Peter Bradshaw dressed
down the whole main cast in his one-star
review for The Guardian, calling Emilia
Clarke's take on Connor "uninteresting."
1981's The Clash of the Titans attempted to
give Greek mythology the Star Wars treatment,
taking the story of Perseus and turning it into
a sprawling epic. Director Desmond Davis went
with Harry Hamlin in the role of Perseus, a son
of Zeus who in legend beheads the Gorgon Medusa
in order to save his beloved Princess Andromeda
from a giant Kraken. Hamlin remains active in
the industry, though he's still arguably
best remembered for his turn as Perseus.
The same cannot be said for Sam Worthington,
best known as the star of James Cameron's
budding Avatar franchise. Director Louis
Leterrier entrusted the Australian with
the lead role in his 2010 remake, though his
choice was called into question when the negative
reviews started to pour in. Worthington's
earned his share of acclaim over the years,
but the Titans remake is one release he most
likely wouldn't mind leaving off his résumé;
Quickflix's Simon Miraudo questioned how
Worthington had ever managed to become a
Hollywood actor after watching his
performance as Perseus, in which
"[He] does nothing but glare.
His battle speeches are neither
rousing nor particularly intelligible."
Despite its name, 1984's Friday the
13th Part 4: The Final Chapter was
far from the last installment in this
long-running horror franchise. In fact,
eight more films have been made since the
so-called final chapter, though the one that
directly followed it marked a major dropoff
in quality. Part 4 has been described as,
"One of the last really excellent horror romps
that focus on character dynamic and family."
Felix Vasquez of Cinema Crazed
praised Corey Feldman for his
"standout performance as young Tommy Jarvis."
Feldman went on to make a name for himself in
The Goonies, Stand by Me, and The Lost Boys,
though before he did, he reprised his Friday
the 13th role in 1985's Part 5: A New Beginning.
Unfortunately, he only appeared in the prologue,
and a time jump meant he was replaced by the
painfully dull John Shepherd. Teenage Tommy
was static compared to his younger self,
though Shepherd shouldn't shoulder the blame
entirely. Some blamed what they called the
"hamfisted directing" of David Steinmann
while James Kendrick of Q Network argued that
"[The] gory antics are so restrained by the
insistence of the MPAA rating system that the film
feels like it was edited with one
of Jason's bloody-rusty weapons."
Wesley Snipes rejected the opportunity to return
as Willie Mays Hayes in 1994's Major League 2
because he had become a movie star
in his own right by then. With the
Cleveland Indians down a man, the
filmmakers turned to Omar Epps.
Director David S. Ward had worked with Epps on
The Program the previous year, which was a sports
movie following the exploits of a college football
team. The big difference between the two films,
however, was that The Program wasn't meant to be
funny. Epps didn't have a background in comedy,
and it showed in his timing. Even those who didn't
think the film was all that bad admitted that,
"Omar Epps taking over for Wesley Snipes was a
complete bomb of a decision. Bad all around."
Veteran film critic Mark Kermode summed up 2015's
The Transporter Refueled with a single question:
"What exactly is the point of a
'Transporter' movie without Jason Statham?"
When it was revealed that Ed Skrein
was to replace Statham as Special
Forces op-turned-private driver Frank
Martin in the fourth Transporter film,
questions were raised about the former's
ability to carry the franchise forward.
Though the Transporter films didn't exactly change
the action movie landscape, they benefited from
Statham's presence, athletic prowess, and combat
skills. His replacement lacked that experience,
and it showed. Skrein began taking classes
in various martial arts disciplines as he
prepared for both The Transporter Refueled
and his role as Ajax in Deadpool, but
even he acknowledged that he was way behind many
of his peers in that department. He told the BBC,
"I'm very respectful and realize I'm not going to
be able to do things meant for
10 or 20 years of training."
The action in The Transporter Refueled
was ultimately limited by the new star's
fledgling abilities. Ed Skrein's one and only
outing as Frank Martin was a commercial and
critical flop that left the Luc Besson
-produced franchise dead in the water.
Rooney Mara took on the role of androgynous
computer hacker Lisbeth Salander starring
opposite Daniel Craig in 2011's The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo. When the 2018 sequel The Girl
in the Spider's Web was announced, fans of David
Fincher's critically acclaimed first film were a
little disappointed that both Mara and Craig had
been recast, and so was Mara. She told Yahoo!,
"I was hopeful to come back, but
they decided to do a different
thing. It was always a character I wanted
to revisit, but that's not what happened."
Sverrir Gudnason replaced Daniel Craig,
while Claire Foy stepped into the pale,
pierced skin of Salander. Unfortunately, she
didn't look comfortable in it. At the time,
she was receiving acclaim for her turn as
the young Queen Elizabeth II in The Crown,
but Foy couldn't pull off Salander's
cold eccentricities with the same poise
as her predecessor. Critics were by and large
unimpressed with her version of the goth hacker,
with many questioning why she was chosen
for the part. The Observer's Wendy Ide said,
"Much as I admire her, Foy is miscast
here. She’s just too empathetic for a
role that requires an almost
reptilian lack of emotion."
IndieWire's senior film critic David Ehrlich
called her both "terrible [and] terribly miscast."
The first RoboCop stars Peter Weller as the
titular cyborg. He roams a dystopian crime-ridden
version of Detroit, mercilessly dealing with
lawbreakers. Weller reprised the role in RoboCop
2 but turned down the chance to play him again
in a third movie. Producers needed a replacement,
and their hearts were apparently set on a
little-known actor named Robert John Burke.
In a 2015 interview, Burke said,
"In God's great earth they thought I
was the only actor who could do it,
I don't know why. I think physically I
poked like Peter Weller, and I had also had
extensive karate training, pantomime training,
and body training, and I fit the suit."
Unsurprisingly, handing the lead role over to
the relatively inexperienced Burke just because
he kind of resembled Weller didn't work out very
well. He may have looked like him in the suit,
but as the New York Times said in
its review of the box office bomb,
"[Burke is] lacking his forerunner's
tongue-in-cheek glint of authoritarian machismo."
"You have the right to an attorney"
"What is thiiiiiis?"
From his delivery to the way he moved,
Burke just wasn't as convincing as RoboCop.
As Empire noted, he appeared to be "a
lot less comfortable with the hardware."
1988's Big is often cited as Tom Hanks'
breakout movie, but he actually announced
himself as a potential star some four years
earlier in Ron Howard's fantasy rom-com
Splash. Hanks plays Allen Bauer, a young man
who returns to the spot of what he believes
was a near-death hallucination to discover that
the woman he saw in the water the day he almost
drowned is indeed real. Allen falls for mermaid
Madison and ditches his life on land to live
under the sea with her in a goofy yet undeniably
feel-good ending. It's a beloved movie,
though the same cannot be said about the
obscure, made-for-TV sequel, Splash, Too.
Helmed by writer, director, and actor Greg
Antonacci, the highly forgettable and completely
unnecessary Splash, Too brought Allen and
Madison back to dry land, totally ignoring
the fact that the government wanted to lock
her up in a lab in the previous installment.
Todd Waring took over as Allen Bauer, but despite
his best efforts, he lacked the everyman charm and
comedic timing that was abundant in Hanks.
Film Fad said in its review of the sequel,
"The less said about the actors replacing
Tom Hanks and John Candy the better."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.